PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THE GIRLS STRUGGLED WITH
A RISQUÉ PHOTO SHOOT
THAT PUSHED REBECCA
OUT OF HER COMFORT ZONE...
I'M THINKING, "OH, JEEZ,
I DON'T WANT TO DO THIS.
"GET ME OUT
OF HERE."
AT JUDGING, ALL THE GIRLS
FAILED THE TEST
WITH THE TELEPROMPTER...
MEJENTA.
MAGNETA?
AND TIFFANY SEEMED TO BE
GIVING UP ON HERSELF.
I CAN'T DO THIS.
YES, YOU CAN.
I CAN'T.
OVERALL, THE JUDGES
WERE UNIMPRESSED...
THE GIRLS TONIGHT
DID HORRIBLY.
I'M NOT SEEING DRIVE.
THEY NEED A WAKE-UP CALL.
SO WE MADE
A DRASTIC DECISION...
BOTH OF YOU WILL PACK
YOUR BAGS.
AFTER BOTH TIFFANY AND REBECCA
WERE ELIMINATED,
TIFFANY'S FLIPPANT ATTITUDE
TRULY UPSET ME.
THIS IS A JOKE TO YOU.
I BEEN THROUGH STUFF
SO I'M ANGRY.
BUT THIS IS NOT--
BE QUIET, TIFFANY.
BUT EVERYBODY DON'T--
BE QUIET! STOP IT!
I HAVE NEVER IN MY LIFE YELLED
AT A GIRL LIKE THIS.
NOW AFTER
THE SURPRISE DOUBLE CUT,
ONLY SEVEN GIRLS
REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
I CANNOT BELIEVE
WHAT JUST HAPPENED.
ELIMINATION
WAS CRAZY.
I WASN'T REALLY EXPECTING,
YOU KNOW,
WHAT HAPPENED
TONIGHT.
BOTH OF YOU
WILL PACK YOUR BAGS.
COME ON,
COME ON.
GOOD LUCK.
TIFFANY, I'M EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTED IN YOU.
DID YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAD
A POSSIBILITY TO WIN?
AND THEN YOU COME IN HERE
AND TREAT THIS LIKE A JOKE.
MAYBE I AM ANGRY
INSIDE.
I BEEN THROUGH STUFF
SO I'M ANGRY.
BUT THIS IS NOT--
UNH, UNH, UNH.
BE QUIET, TIFFANY.
BE QUIET!
WHAT IS WRONG
WITH YOU?
STOP IT!
WHEN MY MOTHER YELLS LIKE THIS,
IT'S BECAUSE SHE LOVES ME!
I WAS ROOTING
FOR YOU!
WE WERE ALL
ROOTING FOR YOU!
HOW DARE YOU!
LEARN SOMETHING
FROM THIS!
TIFFANY COULD HAVE WON.
SHE COULD HAVE BEEN
THE TOP MODEL, BUT...
EVERYBODY WAS ROOTING FOR HER,
EXCEPT FOR HERSELF.
THEY ELIMINATED
BOTH OF THEM.
HELLO.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
HOW ARE YOU GUYS DOING?
GOOD.
I WANTED TO TALK TO YOU GUYS
ABOUT JUDGING BECAUSE I BLEW UP,
AND IT WAS PROBABLY SCARY
FOR YOU GUYS.
BUT I JUST WANT YOU
TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE THAT COMES FROM.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
TIMES WHEN YOU MAY FEEL LIKE
YOU WANT TO GO HOME
AND WANT TO GIVE UP.
I'VE BEEN
THROUGH THAT.
CALLING MY MOM
WHEN I LIVED IN PARIS,
LIKE, "I CAN'T
DO THIS ANYMORE,"
'CAUSE I WENT THROUGH
HORRIBLE THINGS IN THE INDUSTRY.
PEOPLE TRYIN' TO DO
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER
TO MAKE ME GO HOME
AND TO MAKE ME GIVE UP.
WITH TIFFANY, I THINK SHE'S JUST
BEEN THROUGH SO MUCH,
SHE CAN'T SEE
HOW SPECIAL SHE IS.
AND WHEN I SAW HER GIVE UP
IN THAT JUDGING ROOM,
IT JUST
PISSED ME OFF.
BECAUSE I'M,
LIKE,
THIS IS A TURNING POINT
IN YOUR LIFE, YOU KNOW?
YOU SINK
OR YOU SWIM.
AND TO SEE SOMEBODY
JUST LAUGH AT IT
AND THROW IT AWAY
JUST REALLY UPSET ME.
WE ALL SAW
THE DEFEATED THING ALSO.
LIKE, SHE HAD ALREADY GIVEN UP
AND WE ALL SAW THAT.
I JUST WANTED YOU GUYS
TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE THAT
WAS COMING FROM FROM ME.
ALL RIGHT?
TIFFANY--HER HEART
WASN'T IN IT.
I REALLY FELT LIKE
SHE WAS VERY PASSIVE ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE TO JUST TAKE IT
INTO OUR OWN HANDS
OF WHAT WE WANT
TO HAPPEN FOR OUR--
YOU KNOW,
OUR FUTURE.
I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND
HOW MUCH IT IS ABOUT
GIVING YOUR ALL,
AND HOW MUCH IT IS ABOUT
FIGHTING UNTIL THE END.
IT'S AN EMOTIONAL
ROLLER COASTER HERE.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S ONLY GONNA HAPPEN TO ME
ONCE
IN MY LIFETIME.
YOU KNOW,
I WANT TO PROVE TO PEOPLE THAT
EVEN THOUGH I AM NOT AS PRETTY
AS SOME OF THESE GIRLS,
YOU KNOW, I'M GONNA DO IT
NO MATTER WHAT.
OKAY, BYE.
THAT MADE ME FEEL
A LOT BETTER.
YOU SURE,
MICHELLE?
MICHELLE'S GONNA SAY,
"I SHOULDA DONE
SO MUCH BETTER."
NO, I BEEN WORKING
ON THAT.
THAT'S WHY I JOKE
ABOUT IT.
I KNOW YOU HAVE,
I CAN TELL.
I AM HARD ON MYSELF
AND EVERYTHING,
BUT I'M TRYING TO STOP
BEATING MYSELF UP
OVER THINGS
THAT I CAN'T CHANGE.
THROUGH THIS ENTIRE PROCESS,
MY SELF-CONFIDENCE HAS GROWN.
AND HOPEFULLY THE JUDGES SEE
THAT I DO HAVE MORE CONFIDENCE
BECAUSE I DO ACTUALLY
FEEL BEAUTIFUL NOW.
NOW THAT SARAH AND NOELLE
AND BECCA AND LLUVY ARE GONE,
KEENYAH AND CHRISTINA AND I
ARE GONNA MOVE INTO BEL-AIR.
TATIANA, OKAY.
THEY'RE ALL
TATIANA?
SHE'S GONNA SHARE,
AS OF NOW.
THE OTHER GIRLS SEEM LIKE
THEY'RE REALLY CLOSE.
THEY HAVE A LOT
OF FUN TOGETHER.
I JUST DON'T FEEL LIKE
I'M REALLY IN THAT GROUP,
SO I'M JUST, LIKE,
KIND OF BUMMED A LITTLE BIT.
TYRA MAIL.
GONNA READ IT
OUT LOUD.
"EVER BEEN VISITED BY
AN EXTRATERRESTRIAL?
"BE READY TO LEAVE
AT 1:00."
"EVER BEEN VISITED BY
AN EXTRATERRESTRIAL?"
NO.
♪♪♪
WE SHOW UP AT
THE RENAISSANCE HOTEL,
WALK INTO THIS SUITE
ON THE TOP FLOOR.
HI, EVERYBODY.
HI THERE.
HELLO.
WELL, HI.
MY NAME'S
JANN CARL.
I'M A CORRESPONDENT AND ANCHOR
FOR "ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT."
AND I AM HERE TODAY
TO TEACH YOU HOW TO ACT
WHEN YOU ARE THROWN
INTO THE MEDIA SPOTLIGHT.
NOW THE TYRA MAIL
MAKES SENSE--
"E.T.,"
"ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT,"
EXTRATERRESTRIAL.
OKAY,
IT ALL MAKES SENSE.
WHEN I INTERVIEW PEOPLE,
MY JOB IS TO BRING OUT
FUNNY STORIES,
AND MAYBE
INTIMATE THINGS.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE REALLY WANT
TO KNOW, RIGHT?
THE SCOOP.
DEEP DOWN,
DIRTY SECRETS.
DIRTY SECRETS-- YES.
IF THERE ARE THINGS
YOU DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT,
THEN YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO LEARN
HOW TO DEAL WITH THAT
IN A GRACIOUS WAY.
SO HERE'S WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO.
YOU EACH GET TO BE
THE INTERVIEWEE
AND THE INTERVIEWER.
ALL RIGHT?
THE INTERVIEWEE HAS JUST WON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
INTERVIEWING IS ONE THING
THAT I LOVE TO DO.
YOU KNOW WHAT--
I'VE GOT THIS ONE IN THE BAG.
THIS ONE
IS EASY.
I DON'T KNOW
ANY OF THESE GIRLS.
PERSONALLY, I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT QUESTIONS TO ASK.
WHATEVER,
YOU KNOW?
IT'S NOT SO EASY
BEING AN INTERVIEWER.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTES.
SO, YOU KNOW,
MAKE IT GOOD.
THERE'S
YOUR CAMERA.
READY,
SET, GO.
♪♪♪
GOOD EVENING,
THIS IS KEENYAH.
AND I AM HERE
WITH "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
WINNER NAIMA.
WELL, CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR WIN.
I MEAN,
HOW DOES IT FEEL?
IT'S AWESOME.
IT'S AMAZING.
IT'S AN AMAZING--
THIS WOULD BE A TIME TO THROW
SOMETHING VERY PERSONAL IN,
'CAUSE "AMAZING" AND "WONDERFUL"
AND "AMAZING"
DOESN'T TELL US
ANYTHING ABOUT YOU.
HAVING TO INTERVIEW
PEOPLE,
IT'S GONNA COME UP
IN MY CAREER
SO IT'S GOOD PRACTICE.
ANYONE IN THE HOUSE YOU EVER
WANTED TO JUST STRANGLE?
HER NAME
WAS BRITTANY.
SHE ALWAYS WANTED TO BE
IN THE LIMELIGHT.
SHE, YOU KNOW--
YOU MAY NOT WANT TO GIVE AWAY
THAT MUCH INFORMATION.
ALL RIGHT,
30 MORE SECONDS.
I'M STUCK.
BUT INSTEAD
OF GETTING STUCK,
SOMETIMES I'LL JUST
KEEP TALKING
AND THEN
SOMETHING WILL COME TO ME.
I THOUGHT
I WAS VERY CONFIDENT.
BUT, ACTUALLY,
WHEN I GOT UP THERE,
I ENDED UP
A LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT IT.
YOU HAVE NEVER HAD
A BOYFRIEND.
NOW THAT
YOU'VE WON,
HAS YOUR PHONE
BEEN RINGING OFF THE HOOK?
YES, I'M ACTUALLY DATING
A COUPLE OF PEOPLE.
UM, THERE'S A FEW CELEBRITIES
IN MY LIFE NOW--
YOU KNOW,
ADAM BRODY,
COLIN FARRELL.
KAHLEN
CHEATED.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
TO BE YOURSELF AND BE HONEST.
WE WEREN'T GETTING A SENSE
OF WHO SHE WAS.
I WAS
A LITTLE PATHETIC,
BUT I'M STILL
GETTING THERE.
WHEN YOU GOT
TO THE FINAL TWO GIRLS,
WHAT WAS REALLY RUNNING
THROUGH YOUR HEAD?
I KNEW IT WAS
IN THE BAG.
I HAD THIS COMPETITION
SINCE DAY ONE.
MORE REALITY,
MORE REALITY.
YOU WOULDN'T
REALLY SAY THAT.
OH, I REALLY WOULD.
NO, I'M JUST
KIDDING.
YOU REALLY SHOULDN'T.
YOU REALLY
SHOULDN'T.
OKAY.
HOW DID YOU DEAL WITH
INTIMIDATION IN--
THROUGHOUT
THE HOUSE?
I'M KIND OF
SHY AND TIMID,
BUT I JUST
CONTINUED TO GROW
AND DEVELOP MYSELF
AS A PERSON.
I LOVE
MICHELLE'S NATURALNESS.
SHE DOESN'T REALLY TRY
TO BE ANYBODY ELSE.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO THIS
BECAUSE THE JUDGES HAVE TOLD ME
THAT, YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES I COME ACROSS
KIND OF COLD.
THIS IS A CHANCE FOR ME
TO SHOW THAT DEEP DOWN,
I AM A WARM-HEARTED
PERSON.
THREE, TWO...
HI, I'M CHRISTINA
WITH "ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT,"
AND WE ARE ACTUALLY HERE WITH
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL--
TATIANA.
HI, TATIANA.
HOW ARE YOU TONIGHT?
I'M DOING GREAT,
HOW ARE YOU?
GOOD.
ACTUALLY, I HAVE
A FEW QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
ACTUALLY
I WAS WONDERING,
HAS THERE BEEN ANY DESIGNERS
OR ANY MODELS
THAT HAVE INSPIRED YOU
OR ANY FAMILY MEMBERS?
ACTUALLY, UM,
MY COUSIN--
HE'S ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW,
ALWAYS PUSHED ME AND PUSHED ME.
AND MYSELF.
I PUSHED MYSELF A LOT,
ACTUALLY.
THAT'S AWESOME.
ACTUALLY, NOW THAT YOU, UM,
HAVE SIGNED WITH--
WAIT, WAIT.
NEITHER ONE OF YOU IS ALLOWED TO
USE THE WORD "ACTUALLY" AGAIN.
OH, SORRY.
ACTUALLY.
OKAY, NOW THAT YOU
HAVE SIGNED WITH FORD,
CAN YOU TELL ME A DESIGNER
OR AN AD CAMPAIGN
THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO DO?
ACTUALLY,
I'M WEARING VERSACE RIGHT NOW--
ACTUALLY.
OH, GOD! OKAY.
IT IS A LOT MORE DIFFICULT
THAN YOU ACTUALLY THINK IT IS.
SO I'M GLAD WE HAD
THE EXPERIENCE ACTUALLY.
♪♪♪
TONIGHT
ME AND THE GIRLS
ARE GOING TO EL CENTRO,
THE DANCE CLUB.
WE'RE ALL DRESSED UP
AND READY TO GO.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN
TO A CLUB IN INDIANA,
LET ALONE
IN L.A.,
SO I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT TO EXPECT.
THIS IS DEFINITELY
GONNA BE FUN.
(dance music playing)
WE GO OUT
TO THE DANCE FLOOR.
IT'S, LIKE,
CLUB IS PACKED.
MICHELLE IS GETTING
REALLY CRAZY.
WE HAD NO IDEA
SHE HAD THAT MUCH RHYTHM.
I TURNED AROUND,
I WAS LIKE,
"WHOA! MICHELLE,
"WHERE DID THIS
COME FROM?"
SHE JUST COMPLETELY CONVERTS
INTO THIS CONFIDENT WOMAN.
I REALIZE
THAT BLONDES
DEFINITELY HAVE
A LITTLE MORE FUN.
THAT WAS THE MOST FUN
I'VE HAD SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE.
'CAUSE, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
WE JUST LET LOOSE.
KIND OF SEPARATE YOURSELF
FROM THE COMPETITION
FOR THAT
BRIEF MOMENT.
IT WAS FUN.
♪♪♪
(dialing phone)
I CHECKED MY MESSAGES
AND FOUND OUT
THAT ONE OF THE GIRLS
I WAS VERY GOOD FRIENDS WITH
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE BIT YOUNGER
HAD PASSED AWAY.
DAMN IT!
I WAS, LIKE,
COMPLETELY SHOCKED.
I DON'T KNOW
IF I CAN HANDLE THIS.
(crying)
♪♪♪
TODAY WAS PROBABLY
THE WORST DAY I'VE HAD
SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE.
YOU KNOW, I FIND OUT THAT ONE OF
MY FRIENDS AT HOME HAS DIED.
IT'S REALLY HARD
TO HAVE
A FRIEND JUST RIPPED AWAY
FROM YOU,
AND YOU
NOT EVEN SEE IT COMING.
I'M TRYING TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT
I HAVE ENOUGH STRENGTH
TO DO THIS COMPETITION.
IT'S JUST HARD
'CAUSE THIS COMPETITION'S
SO COMPETITIVE RIGHT NOW.
LIKE, YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T
HAVE TIME TO...
BREAK DOWN.
I KINDA JUST TRIED
TO PUT IT IN THE BACK OF MY HEAD
AND NOT THINK ABOUT IT
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
IT'S GONNA SHOW
IN MY PERFORMANCES,
AND THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING I WANT.
♪♪♪
"THIS IS THE EVE
OF YOUR FIRST TIME
"IN THE MEDIA
SPOTLIGHT.
"BE READY
AT THE CRACK OF DAWN."
WHAT'S THE CRACK OF DAWN?
WHAT THE HELL'S
THE CRACK OF DAWN?
WHEN THE SUN
COMES UP?
LET ME SEE.
♪♪♪
WE'RE WALKING UP
THESE STAIRS,
GOING INTO
THIS LOBBY
AND WE'RE LIKE,
"WHERE ARE WE AT?
"WHAT ARE WE DOING?"
HELLO, LADIES.
HI.
I UNDERSTAND THAT YESTERDAY
YOU LEARNED WHAT IT IS LIKE
TO BE IN
THE MEDIA SPOTLIGHT.
YES.
OKAY.
WELL, TODAY, WE'RE GONNA
PUT IT TO THE TEST.
WE'RE GONNA DO
A CHALLENGE
AND WE ARE GONNA BE REVIEWED
BY JANN,
THE LADY
FROM "ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT."
WITH THIS
COMPETITION,
YOU HAVE TO BE 100% FOCUSED
ON EVERYTHING YOU DO NOW.
I DON'T WANT STUFF IN MY LIFE
THAT'S AFFECTING ME
TO AFFECT
MY PERFORMANCE.
BRITTANY, WE'RE GONNA
BE STARTING WITH YOU.
I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT'S GONNA BE BEHIND THE DOOR.
OH, MY GOSH.
HI.
I'M AM FLIPPING OUT.
IT'S EVE,
IT'S EVE.
I LOVE EVE.
SO, BRITTANY,
YOU'RE NOT ACTUALLY
BEING INTERVIEWED TODAY.
YOU'RE GONNA BE
INTERVIEWING EVE
ABOUT HER NEW FASHION COLLECTION
CALLED FETISH.
SO YOU'VE GOT
FIVE MINUTES.
GOOD LUCK.
PLEASURE
TO MEET YOU.
I'M, LIKE,
STARSTRUCK RIGHT NOW.
I CANNOT
EVEN FUNCTION.
SO WH-WHAT, UM...
SO WHAT WAS YOUR INSPIRATION
FOR FETISH?
UM, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I FIGURED I WEAR SO MANY
OTHER DESIGNERS' CLOTHES,
WHY NOT?
THAT'S GREAT,
THAT'S WONDERFUL.
BRITTANY--
REALLY GOOD ENERGY
BUT ALMOST EVERY TIME
SHE FINISHED ANSWERING,
"THAT'S GREAT,
THAT'S WONDERFUL!
"THAT'S AMAZING!"
THAT IS
FANTASTIC.
OH, YOU ARE
SO BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU.
GOD, YOU'RE GORGEOUS.
I'M SO PLEASED
TO BE HERE WITH YOU.
OH,
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
WELL,
YOU LOOK GREAT.
THANK YOU.
DEFINITELY
LOOK WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU.
WOW, UM...
SO IS THIS SOMETHING
THAT YOU SAY
YOUNG PEOPLE
CAN WEAR?
OR IS IT
A VARIETY OF, YOU KNOW,
THINGS THAT PEOPLE
CAN WEAR?
UM, IT'S DEFINITELY
A VARIETY--
FROM YOUNG TEENS
TO GROWN WOMEN.
THAT IS
REALLY WONDERFUL.
I REALLY LIKE IT.
THANK YOU.
IT'S PRETTY WONDERFUL.
SO, YOU KNOW, TELL ME
ARE THERE ANY--
IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU FEEL...
I KINDA LOST
TRAIN OF THOUGHT.
JANN TOLD US THE DAY BEFORE
TO JUST KIND OF BABBLE ON A BIT
AND YOU'LL KIND OF
DEVELOP A QUESTION.
IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON, LIKE,
WITH OTHER
CELEBRITIES
AND OTHER RAPPERS
AND SINGERS,
YOU KNOW,
LIKE YOURSELF
THAT,
YOU KNOW, YOU THINK
THEY WOULD WANT
TO ACCOMPLISH AS WELL?
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT--
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE CAN, YOU KNOW, GO OUT
AND SAY,
"I WANT TO DO THIS,"
OR,
"OH, I WANNA DO THAT"?
UM, AS FAR AS WHAT?
SO AT ANY POINT
IN YOUR CAREER,
DID YOU FEEL LIKE
THAT YOU JUST COULDN'T GO ON
AND YOU COULDN'T DO IT
AND THAT YOU JUST WANTED
TO FLAT OUT GIVE UP?
I THINK EVERYBODY GOES THROUGH
THAT-- I DEFINITELY HAVE.
THERE ARE TIMES
WHERE I'VE BEEN,
YOU KNOW, CRYIN'
AND STRESSED OUT.
BUT I THINK, YOU KNOW,
JUST BELIEVE IN YOURSELF.
IF YOU FEEL LIKE YOU CAN DO IT,
YOU DEFINITELY CAN.
JEEZ.
I'M SWEATING.
ME, TOO, GIRL,
IT'S HOT.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT--
WE ALL SWEAT.
I DID HORRIBLE.
I WAS
JUST STUCK.
I BLEW
THIS ONE, TOO.
I'M SO
DISTRACTED
AND I'M FOCUSING ON
OTHER THINGS
EVEN THOUGH,
YOU KNOW,
I WAS TRYING
TO PUSH IT OUT OF MY HEAD.
ARE YOU DATING ANYONE
RIGHT NOW?
I AM
NOT SINGLE.
SO YES,
I AM DATING SOMEONE.
NO MORE DETAILS
THAN THAT?
NO.
KAHLEN DID GET EXTRA POINTS
FOR BEING THE ONLY ONE
WHO WENT
FOR THE PERSONAL QUESTION.
WILL YOU BE HAVING, LIKE,
YOUR OWN STORE
THAT FEATURES
FETISH?
WE WILL PROBABLY,
AT SOME POINT,
DO A FREESTANDING
FETISH STORE.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO KNOW,
YOU KNOW,
WILL IT BE IN THEIR PRICE RANGE
AND THEIR BUDGET?
TATIANA CAME RIGHTIN,
AND SHE WAS
THROWING QUESTIONS.
I HAD TO STEP BACK
FROM HER
AND GO, "OOH,
LET ME GET IT TOGETHER."
SHE WAS
A REALLY GOOD INTERVIEWER.
I SAID, "SO WHAT STORES
CAN WE FIND THE CLOTHING IN,
THE CLOTHING LINE IN?"
OH, THAT IS GOOD.
THAT'S TERRIFIC.
I THINK TATIANA'S GOT IT.
TATI, REMEMBER ME
WHEN YOU WIN.
AT THIS POINT,
I FEEL REALLY GOOD
ABOUT THE COMPETITION
AND MAYBE I COULD WIN
THIS ONE,
AND IT WOULD BE GOOD
TO WIN IT.
I WAS NERVOUS, BUT ONCE
I STARTED ASKING HER QUESTIONS,
THE NERVES
JUST WENT AWAY.
BECAUSE YOU GOTTA
PULL IT TOGETHER.
AND YOU GOTTA
BE PROFESSIONAL.
DO YOU THINK YOU'LL DO
ANYTHING AS FAR AS,
LIKE, COUTURE?
WE WILL DO
SOME SPECIAL PIECES,
BUT NOT
RIGHT NOW, NO.
IS THERE ANYONE
THAT INSPIRES YOU IN INDUSTRY?
BEFORE I EVEN SIGNED CONTRACTS
WITH MY LINE,
PUFF WAS
THE FIRST PERSON I CALLED.
OUT OF ALL OF THE LINES, I THINK
I'M INSPIRED MOST BY HIS.
CHRISTINA WAS FULLY OF AWARE
OF EVE, HER LINE
AND THAT WAS
REFLECTED IN HER QUESTIONS.
WELL, I WANT
TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT THE WINNER
OF THIS CHALLENGE
WILL ACTUALLY GET
THEIR INTERVIEW WITH EVE
ON
"ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT."
OVERALL, I REALLY I THOUGHT
YOU GUYS DID GOOD.
BUT I DO
HAVE TO PICK SOMEBODY.
THE WINNER
OF THE CHALLENGE...
IS CHRISTINA.
OH, THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS IS MY FIRST CHALLENGE
I'VE WON,
AND I NEEDED IT
BECAUSE I KNEW
GOING INTO THIS CHALLENGE
THIS WEEK--
CHRISTINA, YOU GOTTA STEP IT UP
WITHIN YOURSELF.
I'M A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED
THAT I DIDN'T WIN,
BUT CONGRATULATIONS
TO CHRISTINA.
I MEAN, SHE DID
A GOOD JOB,
SO SHE DESERVES
TO WIN.
♪♪♪
THINGS IN THE HOUSE
ARE, LIKE, TENSE.
IT'S NERVE-RACKING BECAUSE
NOW THERE'S SEVEN GIRLS LEFT.
IT'S THE END
OF THE STRETCH.
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE ROUNDING
SECOND BASE,
AND YOU WANNA
GET HOME.
SO EVERYONE'S
ON EDGE RIGHT NOW.
THIS ROOM'S A MESS,
AND I CANNOT TAKE IT.
WHOSE IS THIS?
I'M GONNA
THROW IT AWAY.
IT'S INTERFERING
WITH MY SPACE I'VE CREATED.
TATI?
YEAH?
WE'RE ALL GONNA
TRY OUR BEST
TO MAKE THIS
A NICE, CLEAN ENVIRONMENT.
TATIANA'S LIKE,
"I DON'T CARE."
LIKE, YOU KNOW,
SHE'S SO PASSIVE ABOUT IT.
IT'S JUST GETTING
ON MY NERVES,
THIS IS
SO IRRITATING.
THERE IS STUFF
EVERYWHERE.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HELL
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT IT.
I'M LIKE, "WHY IS SHE TALKING
TO ME LIKE THIS?"
IT'S JUST LIKE
HOW IT WAS IN SCHOOL.
I NEVER HAD
A LOT OF FRIENDS.
THAT'S KIND OF
HOW IT IS IN THIS HOUSE.
I JUST HAVE NOTHING IN COMMON
WITH THESE PEOPLE, YOU KNOW?
I DON'T REALLY GET ALONG
WITH ALL OF THE GIRLS.
I'M NOT SAYING
THAT THEY DON'T LIKE ME,
I'M JUST SAYING THAT
THEY DON'T SEEM TOO FOND OF ME,
BUT I'LL HAVE
TO GET OVER IT.
TYRA MAIL.
IT SAYS, "TOMORROW
YOU'LL FINALLY GET TO REST
"IN PEACE AND QUIET.
"BE READY TO LEAVE
AT 7:30 A.M.
"TYRA."
WE'RE GONNA
BE DEAD?
"REST IN PEACE."
WE COULD BE
ZOMBIES.
PLEASE DON'T
BE THIS.
I DON'T--I DON'T NEED
DEALING WITH DEATH RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T NEED THAT.
IT'S JUST GONNA BE
A REALLY HARD DAY TOMORROW
IF THAT'S
WHAT IT IS.
(whispers)
I KNOW.
I JUST HOPE THAT
THAT'S NOT WHAT IT IS.
ME TOO.
(thunder rumbling)
OH.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GOIN'?
IT'S A CEMETERY.
I'M SITTING
NEXT TO KAHLEN,
AND SHE IMMEDIATELY
JUST FOLDS OVER
AND STARTS
BAWLING.
(crying)
IT'S REALLY
MESSED UP.
I MEAN, I KNOW
NOBODY KNOWS THE CIRCUMSTANCES,
BUT I JUST DON'T WANT
TO BE HERE.
AND THEN
THERE WERE SEVEN.
AND IN THE WORLD OF MODELING,
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN AT ANY TIME.
WE'VE GOT LUST,
SLOTH,
GLUTTONY,
ENVY, WRATH,
GREED AND PRIDE.
THESE ARE
THE SEVEN DEADLY SINS,
AND WITH SEVEN OF YOU
HERE TODAY,
EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF YOU
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PORTRAY
ONE OF THESE DEADLY SINS
WHILE LOOKING
DEADLY GORGEOUS.
WELL, I HOPE
NONE OF YOU
ARE AFRAID OF TIGHT AND CONFINED
CREEPY SPACES.
FOLLOW ME.
IT TOOK
EVERYTHING IN MY BODY
NOT TO JUST GIVE UP
RIGHT AT THAT MOMENT.
TODAY, YOU GIRLS
ARE GONNA HAVE TO PORTRAY
ONE OF THESE
DEADLY SINS
AT THE BOTTOM
OF THIS 8-FOOT GRAVE.
MY MIND JUST
IS BLANK.
I LITERALLY
JUST BLANK OUT.
♪♪♪
YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA
HAVE TO PORTRAY
ONE OF THESE
SEVEN DEADLY SINS
AT THE BOTTOM OF THIS
8-FOOT GRAVE.
KAHLEN JUST GOT
INFORMATION
THAT ONE OF HER FRIENDS
FROM HIGH SCHOOL
HAD JUST
PASSED AWAY.
I'M FEELING
A LOT OF PAIN RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE KIND
OF SUPPRESSED IT,
AND THIS MORNING, IT JUST KINDA
IS LIKE, BAM, AND IT HITS YOU,
AND YOU DON'T HAVE ANY CHOICE
BUT TO DEAL WITH IT.
NOW I WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER FOR TODAY.
HIS NAME'S JOHANN.
SO, JOHANN, THESE ARE
YOUR SEVEN GIRLS TODAY.
THEY'RE BEAUTIFUL, RIGHT?
WELL, THEY ALL LOOK
TOO ALIVE.
KAHLEN, YOU OKAY,
HONEY?
YEAH.
WHAT'S WRONG?
YOU WANT
TO TALK ABOUT IT?
NOPE.
DO YOU GUYS KNOW
WHAT'S WRONG WITH KAHLEN?
SHE HAD A FRIEND THAT
JUST DIED FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
OH, MY GOSH.
YEAH.
I'LL BE FINE.
DO YOU NEED A MINUTE, LIKE,
TO START HAIR AND MAKEUP?
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT, WHY DON'T YOU
TAKE A BREAK?
SO THIS IS IT.
IT'S DOWN
TO THE WIRE NOW.
I KNOW.
IT'S LIKE EVERY WOMAN
FOR HERSELF.
♪♪♪
SO WHO ARE YOU?
YOU ARE...
I AM SLOTH.
I'M GOING TO BE
PUT DOWN INTO AN 8-FEET GRAVE
AND HAVE TO MAKE THIS LOOK
LOOK SEXY.
HA HA HA.
THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WOULD APPEAR IN, LIKE,
A HIGH FASHION
EUROPEAN MAGAZINE.
RIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
SO YOU STILL
GOTTA THINK MODEL
DON'T THINK FREAK SHOW,
CIRCUS.
OKAY, READY?
LET'S GO DOWN.
SLOWLY. SLOWLY.
ALL RIGHT.
IT FEELS PRETTY CREEPY.
HEY, THINK OF IT THIS WAY.
THE NEXT TIME
YOU'RE LOWERED DOWN,
YOU'LL PROBABLY
BE DEAD.
OH, THANKS, JAY.
♪♪♪
YOU KIND OF LOOK A LITTLE
LIKE "FRIGHT NIGHT."
WHY DO YOU THINK SLOTH
IS A DEADLY SIN?
IS IT JUST,
LIKE, LAZINESS?
WE GET CAUGHT UP
IN ALL SORTS OF THINGS
THAT SLOW US DOWN.
SOMETIMES,
IF IT'S IN YOUR MIND,
IT READS
OVERALL.
ALL RIGHT.
OH, GOOD.
BEFORE, SHE WAS
JUST LYING IN THE BOX
AND SHE WAS GIVING US
A POSE.
THIS--I GET A SENSE
OF SLOTH.
YEAH, THEY PUT
THE MAKEUP ON,
AND IT'S LIKE, UH-HUH,
I'M BEAUTIFUL, UH-HUH.
MICHELLE'S
A LITTLE WEIRD,
SO SHE'S LIKE,
"THIS IS COOL!
"THIS IS COOL."
AND I'M LIKE,
"THIS IS FREAKY."
WE SHOULD HAVE GONE
AND, LIKE, SEEN A ZOMBIE MOVIE
BEFORE WE CAME HERE.
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA,
MICHELLE.
I'M ACTUALLY GLAD
THAT I GOT PRIDE.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE
GIVEN ME THIS,
LIKE,
MY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT,
I WOULD HAVE
FAILED MISERABLY.
NOW THAT
I'M TRANSFORMING,
THIS IS DEFINITELY GONNA BE
A LOT EASIER THAN BEFORE.
GOOD-BYE.
OKAY, MICHELLE,
YOU'RE PROUD.
YOU'RE PRIDE.
ACTUALLY, GIVE ME
A BIG SMILE WITH YOUR TEETH.
YEAH.
MICHELLE WAS GREAT
LAST PHOTO SHOOT.
THIS-- SHE DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT THE HELL TO DO.
YOU'VE GOTTA GIVE ME NECK
WITHOUT STRAINING THE NECK,
WITHOUT MAKING
A FUNNY FACE.
MICHELLE CAME OFF LOOKING
LIKE A BEAUTY QUEEN ON ACID.
I SHOULD HAVE PLAYED
WITH MY CROWN ,THOUGH.
I FORGOT
TO PLAY WITH IT.
I JUST BEAT MYSELF UP BECAUSE,
NO MATTER WHAT I DO,
THERE'S SOMETHING
I COULD HAVE DONE BETTER.
OH, WELL,
I DID MY BEST.
♪♪♪
I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
(crying)
THIS IS A HARD DAY
FOR KAHLEN.
I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE
BEING IN THE MIND-SET
THAT SHE IS
RIGHT NOW.
I'M JUST TRYING
TO COMFORT HER,
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO SEE HER GO HOME
OVER SOMETHING
LIKE THIS.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE
ANOTHER TEST FOR ME,
TO SEE
IF I CAN DO THIS.
I'M JUST--
I'M HEARTBROKEN.
OH, MY GOD!
TODAY MY SIN
WILL BE GREED.
I'M KIND OF
FINDING THIS SIN
A LITTLE DIFFICULT
TO CONVERT INTO
BECAUSE I'M NOT
A GREEDY PERSON.
MAKE LOVE
TO THE MONEY.
JUST FEEL IT
ALL OVER YOU.
IT'S YOUR LOVER.
THERE IS A FINE LINE
BETWEEN IT LOOKING KITSCHY
AND LOOKING LIKE
A HIGH FASHION STORY, OKAY?
I DON'T WANT THIS
TO LOOK LIKE A CIRCUS.
YOU'RE SMELLING
THE MONEY.
YOU'RE SMELLING IT.
TATIANA-- THERE WASN'T REALLY
A LOT OF DIMENSION.
I THINK SHE COULD HAVE PUSHED
A LITTLE FURTHER.
I AM THE SIN OF LUST,
AND I HAVE TO BE VERY SEXUAL.
I FEEL THAT
I'M A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT I DON'T FEEL LIKE I CAN BE
THIS ULTRA-SEXY GIRL.
♪♪♪
SO, UM, I'M GONNA
HAVE TO GO
TO A DIFFERENT
MIND FRAME TODAY
AND PULL THAT OUT.
START THINKING
LUSTY THOUGHTS.
GO DEEPER.
THIS IS ABOUT YOU EXPERIENCING
YOUR BODY AS A LUST MACHINE.
YOU WANT THEM TO ADORE
EVERY PART OF YOUR BODY.
LIKE, LICK
BETWEEN YOUR TOES--
I MEAN
EVERYTHING.
HEY,
BIG BOY.
YOU WANNA
COME ON IN?
10 BUCKS
A POP.
OKAY, 10 BUCKS,
THAT'S A LITTLE CHEAP
BUT, HEY...
OH, YES, IT'S LIKE A LOVER
CARESSING YOU THERE.
OH! AH!
MMM. OH, YEAH.
YES. THERE IT IS.
RIGHT THERE.
THIS IS THE FIRST DAY
WE ACTUALLY GOT SOME EMOTION
OUT OF CHRISTINA,
BUT, OF COURSE,
IT WAS LIKE PULLING TEETH.
♪♪♪
I'M ENVY.
ENVY IS WANTING
EVERYTHING
BECAUSE YOU FEEL
YOU DON'T HAVE ANYTHING.
MY WARDROBE
TODAY
IS JUST A SHEER PIECE
OF GREEN MATERIAL,
THAT'S IT.
I'M ENVIOUS.
YOU GUYS
GOT ON JACKETS.
NICE.
YOU LOOK
BEAUTIFUL.
I'M ENVIOUS.
OH, NAIMA--AS SOON
AS WE LOWERED HER DOWN THERE,
IT WAS JUST
STUNNING.
OKAY, GOOD--
BEAUTIFUL RIGHT THERE.
THIS IS GORGEOUS.
THAT'S FINE, THAT'S FINE,
THAT'S FINE.
MY SIN
WAS GLUTTONY,
WHICH IS JUST LIKE,
GLUTTONY.
LIKE, "OH, I'M GREEDY,
I'M HUNGRY, LIKE RAWR."
YUCK.
(groaning)
OKAY.
I KNOW
YOU'RE GLUTTONY,
BUT YOU'RE
A TALL SLIM GIRL.
I WANT YOU TO STILL LOOK
LIKE A MODEL.
KEENYAH-- IT JUST CAME OFF
LOOKING A LITTLE CAMPY
AS OPPOSED
TO FASHIONY.
DON'T HOLD YOUR TUMMY
LIKE YOU'RE PREGNANT.
OKAY.
I'VE SEEN DRAG QUEENS
SOFTER THAN HER.
I WANT TO JUST TURN AROUND
AND WALK THE OTHER DIRECTION,
BUT I DON'T WANT
TO GET ELIMINATED FOR THIS.
SO I KINDA JUST TRIED
TO NOT THINK ABOUT IT.
I HAD
TO BE WRATH.
WRATH
IS LIKE ANGER.
BUT I'M TRYING
NOT TO FEEL ANYTHING RIGHT NOW,
TO TELL YOU
THE TRUTH.
I WANT YOU TO CHANNEL
ALL OF YOUR ENERGY INTO THIS.
IT'S ACTING.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE
ALL OF YOUR NERVES
AND TAKE ALL OF THAT
AND TURN IT INTO JUST--
LIKE ANGER.
EVERY BIT OF MIGHT
IN YOUR BODY,
I WANT TO SEE IT.
YEAH.
THAT'S GREAT.
JUST KEEP IT
RIGHT THERE.
NOW GIVE ME RAWR.
REALLY DO IT.
GRRR. GROWL.
GRRRR.
DON'T ACT IT--
BE IT.
BE IT--
LIKE, SCREAM.
COME ON, LET'S HEAR IT--
AAH!
LOUDER.
I TRIED TO CONTROL
MY EMOTIONS
AND JUST TAKE
THAT ENERGY
AND JUST BRING IT OUT
IN THE PICTURE.
PUSH THAT
SHOULDER DOWN.
YEAH, AND NOW PUSH.
CLAWS, BIG EYES.
AAH! SCREAM.
AAH!
OKAY, ONE MORE.
OKAY, I GOT IT,
GOOD.
THANK YOU.
IT WAS
REALLY HARD,
BUT I'M REALLY GLAD
I STUCK THROUGH IT
AND DIDN'T, YOU KNOW,
JUST GIVE UP ON MYSELF.
I HOPE I DID WELL ENOUGH
TO PULL OFF A GOOD PICTURE
TO STAY HERE
THIS WEEK,
BUT I GUESS I JUST
HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE.
♪♪♪
AFTER THE SHOOT, I FELT
JUST SO MENTALLY EXHAUSTED.
YOU FEELING OKAY?
DO YOU WANNA GET UP OR DO YOU
WANT TO SLEEP A LITTLE LONGER?
CHRISTINA HAS BEEN HELPING
A LOT, DEALING WITH THIS.
REALLY, I MEAN,
SHE'S PROBABLY
ONE OF THE SWEETEST GIRLS
IN THE HOUSE.
TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY SIX OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
"IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I DID MY BEST.
HOPEFULLY IT'S UP ON
THE SAME LEVEL
AS THE OTHER GIRLS.
MY LAST COUPLE OF SHOOTS
HAVE BEEN NOT VERY GOOD.
I THINK I STEPPED IT UP
THIS PHOTO SHOOT,
BUT I'M NOT
SUPER CONFIDENT.
I REALLY THINK
IT WILL BE ME.
TO BE DROPPED OUT
OF THIS COMPETITION
IS JUST GONNA SHATTER
ALL OF IT FOR ME.
♪♪♪
WELCOME, LADIES.
NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR EIGHTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER
TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
WE HAVE
SOME AMAZING PRIZES.
THE FIRST
IS A CONTRACT
WITH THE TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE, YOU KNOW
THESE CRAZY FOOLS UP HERE--
JANICE IS ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPER MODELS.
THERE SHE GOES AGAIN,
CALLING ME CRAZY.
NIGEL BARKER--
A NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NOLE MARIN--A PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST.
AND JOHANN WOLF,
THE PHOTOGRAPHER THAT
SHOT YOU GUYS THIS WEEK,
AND HE'S ALSO A FIERCE
COMMERCIAL DIRECTOR, TOO.
SOMETIMES BEING IN THE SPOTLIGHT
CAN BE AMAZING,
AND SOMETIMES IT CAN BE A PAIN
IN THE YOU KNOW WHAT.
NOW TODAY'S TEST WILL SEE
HOW YOU HANDLE THAT PRESSURE.
TODAY YOU'LL BE PARTICIPATING IN
A MOCK PRESS CONFERENCE
FOR "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL'S"
NEW CLOTHING LINE.
THE JUDGING PANEL WILL ACT
AS JOURNALISTS
ASKING ABOUT
THE NEW LINE.
BUT WE'RE REALLY GONNA BE
GRILLING YOU
ABOUT THE GOSSIP
THAT WE HEARD ABOUT YOU--
SOME THAT WE HEARD FROM
THE HAIR AND MAKEUP PEOPLE,
AND SOME THAT IS
TOTALLY MADE UP.
HI, MICHELLE.
HI.
TELL ME
ABOUT THIS COLLECTION.
IS IT FOCUSING
FOR HETEROSEXUALS, BISEXUALS?
ACTUALLY, THE LINE
IS FOR ANYBODY.
WE HAVE CLOTHING--
WHAT ARE YOU
SEXUALLY?
I AM ACTUALLY
BISEXUAL,
BUT THAT HAS, I MEAN,
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE LINE.
HMM.
WE HAVE A WONDERFUL LINE
OF CLOTHING
FOR THE NEW GENERATION.
YOU EAT MEAT?
I'M ACTUALLY
A VEGETARIAN.
BUT I COULD SWEAR
I JUST SAW A PHOTO OF YOU
GRUBBIN'
ON A BURGER,
AND IT WAS MEAT.
IS THIS TRUE?
THIS STATEMENT
IS NOT TRUE.
I AM
A REPRESENTATIVE OF
"YOU AND YOUR HAIR WEAVE"
MAGAZINE.
WHAT TYPE OF HAIR WEAVE
WOULD YOU ROCK
WITH THE NEW SEASON
TANK TOPS?
DEFINITELY NOT THE ONE
THAT I HAVE ON MY HEAD
'CAUSE IT'S JUST
OUT OF CONTROL.
CAN YOU LET YOUR HAIR WEAVE DOWN
FOR ME, PLEASE?
YES, IF YOU WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO.
THAT'S THE FIRST SMILE
YOU'VE CRACKED.
BECAUSE SHE'S TALKING
ABOUT HAIR WEAVES.
WE BASICALLY SAW YOU
IN A PHOTOGRAPH
PICKING
YOUR NOSE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY
ABOUT THAT?
WELL, SOMEBODY
FEELS COMFORTABLE
PICKING THEIR NOSE OR--
WHY DON'T YOU JUST
REENACT IT? HOW WAS IT?
GO FOR IT,
GIRLFRIEND.
IT WAS A LITTLE LIKE...
TATIANA HAS DATED
A MAN TWICE HER AGE.
AS A ROLE MODEL,
HOW DO YOU EXPECT
TO SELL CLOTHES
TO YOUNG GIRLS?
IT WASN'T A CLOSE,
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP.
SO YOU MEAN LIKE
AN UNCLE OR--
NOT A SUGAR DADDY,
BUT LIKE AN UNCLE?
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO SAY?
NO.
IT WAS MORE LIKE
A FRIENDSHIP.
WITH BENEFITS?
NO!
NO KISSES?
(imitates choking sound)
UH-HUH!
WE SAW SOME PICTURES
OF YOU,
YOU HAD, LIKE, A BEER
IN THIS HAND AND A 40-OUNCE--
AND YOU WERE ON THE TABLE
WITH PARIS HILTON.
WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT?
I LOVE MAKING
A SCENE
BECAUSE THAT PUTS MY CLOTHING
ON FRONT PAGE NEWS.
PERSONALLY, I SEE
NOTHING WRONG
WITH DANCING
ON TABLETOPS.
DO IT
ALL THE TIME.
ARE YOU GOING TO BE GIVING
A SMALL DONATION TO I.B.S.?
SURE,
I'LL DONATE TO I.B.S.
IT IS A PROBLEM THAT A LOT
OF GIRLS ARE FACING RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE IT.
WHAT ABOUT
SOME OF THE OTHER GIRLS?
DO THEY HAVE
TO WEAR DIAPERS?
AND IS THERE AN "AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL" DIAPER OUT YET?
I'D RATHER NOT DISCUSS THAT
AT THIS TIME.
WE'RE ON A NEED-TO-KNOW BASIS
ABOUT YOUR FLATULENCE.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHTY,
FIRST IS CHRISTINA.
CHRISTINA, YOU HAVE
TO BE SOMEWHAT CAREFUL
BECAUSE WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING,
YOU SOUND LIKE
A BUSINESSWOMAN.
YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE THERE WERE
SEVEN GIRLS
REPRESENTING
THE SEVEN DEADLY SINS.
THIS IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
WOW.
WHO WERE YOU,
CHRISTINA?
WHAT SIN?
I WAS LUST.
IF I MAY BE
A LITTLE BIT CRITICAL,
LUST WAS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU
TO GO TOTALLY OVER THE TOP.
THAT'S
A GOOD POINT, ACTUALLY.
LUST SHOULD
BE LIKE...
SO GIVE ME LUST
RIGHT NOW.
ACTUALLY,
WORK THAT POLE.
GO TO THIS POLE
RIGHT NOW.
WORK THE POLE, HONEY!
WORK THAT POLE,
GIRL!
I DON'T WANT
TO SEE SEXY.
I WANT TO SEE
THAT SIN.
THAT'S IT, OOH!
THAT'S GOOD.
NAIMA.
DURING THE PRESS
CONFERENCE,
I THOUGHT YOU WERE
A BIT REHEARSED-SOUNDING
AND A BIT
STIFF.
THIS STATEMENT
IS NOT TRUE.
I THINK
YOU JUST NEED TO LEARN
TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE NATURAL.
SHE'S ENVY.
OH!
TO DIE FOR.
IT'S TERRIFIC.
TO ME, YOUR FACE
JUST LOOKS REALLY PRETTY,
BUT I WOULD HAVE LIKED TO SEE
KIND OF EVIL LIKE,
"I WANT
WHAT YOU HAVE, BITCH."
KEENYAH.
YOU LET US GET
THE BEST OF YOU.
WHEN YOU GUYS ARE ASKED
SOMETHING THAT'S SO NOT TRUE,
JUST DENY IT.
GLUTTONY LOOKS
LIKE DUMPY.
IT'S LIKE
PIGGY CHIC.
I DON'T LIKE
THIS ONE, KEENYAH.
I DON'T THINK
YOU LOOK LIKE A MODEL.
I WOULD'VE LIKED
TO SEE
THE DOUGHNUT HANGING OUT
YOUR MOUTH.
BRITTANY.
AT THE END, YOU ARE MORE OF
A SPOKESPERSON FOR BEING DRUNK
THAN BEING
A TOP MODEL REPRESENTATIVE.
SO, BRITTANY,
WHAT WERE YOU?
SLOTH.
IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE YOU
LOOK AS SUBTLE AS THIS.
YOU WENT DOWN LAUGHING
AND HAVING A GOOD TIME,
AND THAT MADE
MY JOB EASIER.
AND THAT'S THE ATTITUDE
OF A WINNER.
TATIANA.
AS A SPOKESPERSON,
YOU WERE SHOWING US
A VERY BORING SIDE OF YOU.
THAT WAS NOT
A TOP MODEL.
NO!
IT WAS MORE
LIKE A FRIENDSHIP.
WITH BENEFITS.
NO.
YOU NEED TO PRACTICE
HIDING BEING FRAZZLED.
AND WHAT
WERE YOU?
GREED.
OH, THAT'S NICE.
HEY,
THAT'S SLAMMING.
YOU'RE ACTING.
I'M AFRAID THIS IS ACTUALLY
MY LEAST FAVORITE PICTURE.
I'M LOOKING AT YOU NOW,
AND YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL,
AND LOT OF THE SHOTS
THAT I LOOKED AT YESTERDAY,
YOU LOOKED
A LITTLE STRANGE.
YOUR FACE CAN'T HANDLE
A LOT OF MAKEUP,
SO I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT,
AS WELL.
KAHLEN.
I THOUGHT
YOU WERE REALLY SWEET.
YOU SEEMED REAL
TO ME.
WOW.
AND WHAT WERE YOU?
WRATH.
IT'S GREAT BODY LANGUAGE--
THAT'S FABULOUS.
THAT'S SO GREAT!
DO YOU SEE THE FIERCENESS
OF THIS?
YEAH.
WHAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY,
I THINK, WAS MORE
LIKE AN ACTOR
REALLY PUSHING
THROUGH SOMETHING
THAT WAS GOING ON
PERSONALLY.
WHAT HAPPENED,
HONEY?
NO, IT'S SERIOUS,
JANICE.
OH.
YOU DON'T HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
IT'S OKAY.
THANK YOU.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST
IS MICHELLE.
I DID LIKE
YOUR OPENNESS
WHEN WE ASKED YOU
ABOUT YOUR SEXUALITY.
YOU FEEL
RELATABLE.
IF SHE COULD CONNECT THAT
WITH THE FACE AND THE BODY VIBE,
THEN WE'D HAVE
A WINNER.
(laughter)
OH,
I HATE IT.
YOU LOOK LIKE GAY PRIDE
ON A FLOAT.
YES!
THAT'S WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE.
IT'S GOT TO COME
FROM INSIDE!
YOU HAVE TO START TO BE PROUD
OF WHO YOU ARE.
MICHELLE, WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH YOU?
WELL, UM, LIKE, I MEAN,
I JUST GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL,
AND I'M REALLY TRYING TO,
YOU KNOW,
FIND OUT WHO I AM
AND EVERYTHING.
AND I PUT MY HEART AND SOUL
IN IT,
AND I TRY SO HARD,
SO...
I GUARANTEE YOU,
I'VE HAD YEARS OF WHAT
YOU'RE FEELING RIGHT NOW.
THIS GOES HAND IN HAND
WITH BEING A MODEL.
I'M HERE TO SNAP YOU
INTO GOING TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
IF YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
THESE THINGS,
YOU'RE GONNA GET
THE BOOT.
BRITTANY.
BRITTANY
IS A WILD CHILD
WHO DEFINITELY NEEDS
SOME TRAINING.
SHE DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A FASHION
MODEL IN THIS AT ALL TO ME.
SHE JUST LOOKS LIKE SOMEBODY
THAT WANTS TO BE A MODEL.
TATIANA.
THIS WEEK
I THINK SHE JUST FELL APART.
SHE'S A VERY
PRETTY GIRL.
SHE TAKES
GOOD PICTURES,
BUT SHE HAS NOT LEARNED
TO SPEAK AT ALL.
SHE'LL BE A NICE ARM-PIECE
TROPHY WIFE SOMEDAY.
NAIMA.
JUST LOOKING AT HER,
SHE'S DYNAMITE.
THIS IS A GREAT PICTURE,
AND SHE'S HOT IN THIS PICTURE.
KEENYAH.
SHE JUST KIND OF LOOKS LIKE
A DEAD DRAG QUEEN IN THE COFFIN.
KEENYAH LOOKS LIKE A GIRL
IN AN R&B VIDEO TALKING ABOUT,
"MY MAN LEFT ME,
AND I'M GONNA EAT AN APPLE."
KAHLEN.
KAHLEN WAS HAVING
A REALLY HARD TIME,
BECAUSE SHE JUST FOUND OUT
THAT HER FRIEND DIED,
BUT SHE BROUGHT IT
IN THE PICTURE.
SHE DELIVERS.
SHE REALLY
DELIVERS.
THIS IS ANOTHER
GREAT ONE.
MICHELLE.
SHE REALLY WANTS
TO BE A SUCCESSFUL MODEL.
TO BE A MODEL.
I THINK SHE WANTS IT
MORE THAN ANY GIRL HERE.
NAME ONE CLIENT
THAT WOULD BOOK THIS GIRL.
SHE SHOULD BE WORKING
IN A DINER ON ROLLER SKATES.
CHRISTINA.
HEY, THIS IS
A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
BUT IT'S NOT LUST,
IT'S SEX.
JANICE, DO LUST
TO NIGEL.
(laughs)
OKAY,
YOU CAN STOP.
WHOO!
DON'T EVEN--
GO OVER THERE!
SEVEN BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SIX PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE SIX GIRLS
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
KAHLEN.
KAHLEN, I AM
SO PROUD OF YOU.
YOU REPRESENT
FACING ADVERSITY
AND BEING ABLE
TO GET PAST THAT,
AND I ADMIRE YOU
BECAUSE SOMETIMES
I'M NOT AS STRONG AS THAT.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHRISTINA.
IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT BEING PRETTY.
YOU'RE ONE OF
THE PRETTIEST GIRLS HERE.
BUT WHAT WAS
YOUR ASSIGNMENT?
TO BE LUSTY.
YOU NEED TAKE IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
NAIMA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL--
KEENYAH.
KEENYAH,
I THINK YOU REPRESENT
A BEAUTIFUL ALL-AMERICAN GIRL
NEXT DOOR,
BUT YOU NEED TO BE A GIRL
NEXT DOOR WITH A LITTLE OOMPH.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL--
BRITTANY.
BRITTANY, YOU HAVE ALL
THE PERSONALITY IN THE WORLD,
BUT I THINK SOMETIMES
WHEN YOU GET NERVOUS,
YOU JUST LOSE IT
AND GET A LITTLE SLOPPY.
YOU NEED
TO PULL THAT IN.
THANK YOU.
WILL MICHELLE AND TATIANA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL CALL
ONLY ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT
I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO YOUR LOFT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND LEAVE.
BOTH OF YOU
ARE BEAUTIFUL GIRLS.
IN GENERAL,
YOU TAKE BEAUTIFUL PICTURES,
BUT YOU TWO
ARE THE EXAMPLE
THAT IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT HOW YOU LOOK.
IT'S HOW YOU SPEAK,
HOW ARTICULATE
YOU ARE.
IT'S ABOUT
HAVING SELF-ESTEEM
EVEN WHEN YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU JUST WANT TO CRUMBLE.
THE JUDGES FEEL
ONE OF YOU
MAY HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE POTENTIAL.
MICHELLE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M DEFINITELY GONNA
WORK ON IT.
OKAY.
THANKS, TATIANA.
THANK YOU.
THIS COMPETITION MEANT
A LOT TO ME.
I JUST WISH THAT
I COULD HAVE GONE FURTHER.
I KNOW THAT
I TAKE GORGEOUS PICTURES.
I JUST CAN'T REALLY
HANDLE MYSELF WELL
WHEN I GET NERVOUS.
I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED
IN MYSELF,
BUT I STILL
CAN DO THIS
AND PROBABLY BETTER
WITH THE STUFF THAT
I'VE LEARNED HERE.
STAY TUNED FOR SCENES FROM OUR
NEXT EPISODE.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
MICHELLE
GROWS DISTANT...
MICHELLE,
DO YOU FEEL ALIENATED?
WHILE KEENYAH
GETS CARELESS...
KEENYAH HAS GAINED
ABOUT 10 POUNDS.
AAH!
AND THE GIRLS
PACK THEIR BAGS
FOR AN EXOTIC
LOCATION.
GOOD-BYE, L.A.!